- With law school starting back up,
I thought it be a good time to talk about
the five biggest myths
about law school success,
and how you can do better by working less.
(gentle music)
But first, let's define
what is law school success.
For the most part law school
success is getting good grades
to enable you to get the job that you want
when you graduate from law school.
Law school is a means to an end,
and generally, as a professional school,
is a means to the job
that you want to work
as a career generally for
the rest of your life.
And for most people, that
means working as a lawyer
in the circumstances that they want.
But it would be a pyrrhic victory
to go through law school only
to lose more than you gain.
For example, if you had a heart attack
from all the stress that you were under,
or lost your health because of all
the bad habits that you
gained in law school.
So I wanna talk about
some of the most pernicious myths
about law school success.
And the first one that
most people think of
when they think of law school
is that people work all the time.
Now, certainly, law school is
going to take a lot of work,
but no one can work all the time.
No one can do all-nighter,
after all-nighter,
after all-nighter.
There has to be time for hobbies.
One person once asked me
if they would have time for
their hobbies in law school.
And my response was that
not only is it possible to keep
your hobbies in law school,
but I think it's essential.
Law school is like a gas that expands
to fill the space around it.
Law school will take up all of the time
that you allow it take up.
And of course a lot of that is necessary,
don't get me wrong.
But every has to have a
life outside of law school.
Everybody has to have hobbies
and things they do on the side.
So what I recommend is
paying yourself first.
If your health is important to you,
work out in the morning,
and let law school fill the
available time after that.
If learning to play the
piano is important to you,
carve out an hour of
the day to learn piano
before you do all of your law school work.
And on top of that, when you
focus on the high value work,
you'll have a reasonable amount of time
left over for other things.
Those people that focus on the busy work,
the case briefing, for example,
they might not have all
that much extra time,
because they're doing things
that aren't going to help
them in the final exam.
But if you focus on the high value work,
like synthesizing the
law into your outline,
doing practice exams,
learning the strategies
for testing taking,
you'll have a lot of time left over.
Focus on what's most important
and don't work all the time.
That brings me to the second
myth about law school success,
which is that the smartest people
will always get the best grades.
What's funny is that
it's clear when law school starts
that some people are
extraordinarily smart,
and some people are smarter then others.
But the funny thing is
that those smartest people
are rarely the people
that get the top grades.
Just because you're smart
in an abstract sense,
in an IQ sense,
it doesn't mean that you're going to focus
on the most important things.
And so many people focus
on studying the law alone,
without focusing on how
to take law school exams,
which is an equally important part.
In fact, we did an entire video
on the two keys to success.
One is learning law itself,
and the other is mastering the test.
And if you do one at the
exclusion of the other,
you're probably not gonna do as well.
So just because you are smart
in the sense that you can
memorize things faster
or have a high IQ does not
guarantee success in law school.
The third myth is along the same lines,
and it's that everything in
law school is about hard work.
The hardest workers will
be the most successful.
Just as with the myth about
the smartest people in law school,
just because you work hard,
it doesn't mean that you're
doing work that's important.
There's so much bad
advice about law school,
advice that will cause people to do
far more busy work than is necessary.
There are law school who in
their orientation packets,
tell people that they should case brief
every case in law school,
and that is just a huge waste of time.
But because the law school
is the one that's saying this information,
it would be reasonable
for someone to think that
they should do this work,
and that if they're doing
a huge amount of work
and killing themselves doing case brief
night, after night, after night
that they're getting ahead
when really they're
just running in circles.
So just because you're doing hard work
doesn't mean you're doing the work
that's going to result in a
successful law school career.
Oh, and by the way,
feedback is the one thing
that has been scientifically proven
to increase your grades in law school.
We did a whole video on that.
Check it out in the link below.
Hard work alone does not equal success.
The finally myth about law school success
is that grades are enough.
Now certainly, grades are important,
and they are probably
the most important thing
that you should focus on in law school,
but don't fool yourself to think that
grades alone are enough to
get the job that you want.
The legal field is still a field
that relies on networks.
It relies on who you know.
So, regardless of what job
you want when you graduate,
don't overlook the human element.
Make friends with your professors.
Go into office hours,
make friends with other
attorneys in the field,
other administrators in your law school,
because these are the people
that are going to be able to,
for example, write letters
of recommendations.
These are the people that might
introduce you to other lawyers
who you might want to work for.
They might have connections to big firms.
They might have connections to judges
who you might want to clerk for.
The human element cannot be overstates,
and many law schools have the
on-campus interview process,
and that's great, but not
everybody gets a job through OCI.
You shouldn't put all of
your eggs in one basket,
and you should still try and network
even during your one-L year.
It is much better to go to a professor
whose office hours you went to many times,
and to whom you've demonstrated
a real understanding of the law
and passion for the legal field
to ask that professor for
a letter of recommendation
after the semester is over.
Remember, you're gonna have to apply for
one-L summer jobs
probably at the end of
your first semester,
even before grades come out.
And the only thing, at most, you'll have
are your one-L grades.
So you wanna be able to
talk to professors for
letters of recommendation.
You wanna be able to talk to other lawyers
to perhaps have an
internship, or clerkship,
or summer associateship.
Don't overlook the fact that
you still have to network,
and that grades are seldom enough
to get your dream legal job.
So, don't assume that your
grades are going to be enough.
Maybe you're not gonna get the high grades
that you think you should be entitled to.
You may have to fall back
on that human element.
And regardless, it's always
better to backstop grades
with a personal network
that you developed well in law school
to make sure that you can attain
the perfect legal job when you graduate.
Hopefully that was helpful.
If you like this video, please
click like and subscribe
for more law school freshman tips.
Also, please download
the free checklist below
to ensure your successful
law school career.
From everyone here at Legal Eagle,
thanks for stopping by.
(upbeat music)